gotta lock this down yeah yeah wait Ryan
Reynolds and Blake Lively are basically
relationship bulls guilty as charged
I've done things where I've like blown
halfway across the world to just see my
wife for a day you know because you got
a you got to do that it's really
important for us to have that support
system so we're always there were always
together if not I would nothing would be
worth being around my family
it's pretty remarkable you know it's
like I used to embrace to say to my wife
felt I was like I can never I can't
actually imagine ever loving a second
child as much as I love the first right
and then that that maybe comes popping
out and I acted like I was totally wrong
yeah
he's great and he's so fun about it the
other day we were changing diapers and
and he said you got to get rid of it and
I said okay he goes no not the type of
the child I used to sit her I would take
a bullet for you I would I would I could
never love anything as much as I loved
you I would say that's my wife and then
his second I looked in that baby's eyes
I knew in that exact moment that if we
were ever under attack I would use my
wife as a human shield
he's pretty funny though the things he
says about our daughter are the most and
in gqueues 2016 men of the year issue
Ryan reveals how he knew Blake was the
one quote probably after the sex know we
were hanging out at this little
restaurant and Tribeca that's open
really late and the song came on and I
was just like wanna dance and then I
walked her home and you know I don't
really need to go into what happened
after that
I've always been a little cheeky